parlons jamais lien n'est pas convenable
de se comporter de la sorte c'était de
pierre bien que votre présence parmi
nous ne soit pas à proprement parler un
choix personnel devant le jld pas sachez
qu'un élan tu te faire pour rendre votre
séjour agréable a aussi n'hésitez
surtout pas à nous solliciter si vous
avez besoin de quoi que ce soit vous
vouloir mois donne aille quelque chose
de vous à bruay où je crains de ne pas
avoir bien entendu à boire donne moi à
boire dans le foot
ainsi peu de mots premièrement pour
commencer on ne veut rien on espère au
pire on souhaite
deuxièmement pour continuer nous autres
bretons sommes très à cheval sur le
vouvoiement est choisi un moment pour
finir il a aidé usage dans ce qu'on
exprime une demande de l'agrémenter de
formule de politesse
jf bon pour cette fois
exceptionnellement je vais fait preuve
d'un peu de flexibilité et accéder aux
requêtes ces jo en parodiant qu'en
volume en poison d'un tortueux rts bois
des tâches bonne ou paie cash back par
odense mais xiaot feria je pense que
monsieur fait depuis elle pouvait tout à
fait bénéficier d'un petit le sont
accélérés de savoir vivre